mit zucker und ich habe bereits vor
anderthalb wochen ein video hochgeladen
dem ich euch die lustigsten schüler
beantworten vorgestellt habe schreiben
sie weiter
der schüler schreibt halt weiter ja da
war ganz schön dumme scheiße dabei eine
video ist auf jeden fall ein mega gut
bei euch angekommen und deswegen haben
wir uns gedacht hey klatschende erstmal
ein bisschen jura hat wieder das
internet durchkämmt nach einem
bescheuerten antworten von schülern in
klassenarbeiten tests etc
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
der ersten antwort ex temporale aus der
katholischen religionslehrer ich wüsste
jetzt schon wenn ich was gemeint ist die
erste frage die sind es laut nenne
mindestens drei beispiele für andere
religionen außerdem christentum normaler
gut aufpassen dass schüler aus dem
religionsunterricht wird jetzt was
antworten wie hinduismus oder buddhismus
oder judentum diese person hat
allerdings geschrieben erstens die
dunkle seite der macht
zweitens essen und zu schützen
zu welcher religion gehört du essen
bei diesem test gab es allerdings noch
eine zweite frage und zwar welchen sinn
hat die eucharistiefeier im katholischen
gottesdienst das knappe gut beantworten
also ich mal ganz ehrlich da hat er ein
bisschen recht weil ich meine wir den
eigentlichen wind kennt ja nur die
personen die mehr oder weniger ist also
gott hat ja eine ganze kirche gefunden
aber ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine
ich will das nicht
die aufgabe ist er weitere vier drei
zwei fünftel eigentlich würde man das
jetzt auseinander rechnen und die brüche
ja einfach erweitert haben jeder kennt
das glaube ich allerdings sich dieser
schüler gedacht hey ich weiter das ganze
im rhein da man hier den abstand dann
haben wir schon in 2 cm abstand und dann
haben wir auch noch 1 3 cm abstand
aber aber wirklich jetzt komplett im
ernst ich hätte dafür punkte vergeben
als sehr es ist richtig ich komme mir
allerdings nun hier zu einer aufgabe aus
dem englischunterricht
die erste frage wird richtig beantwortet
haben wenn die denkfabrik das sind 7 im
raum wenn man hier also viele monate hat
ein jahr auf zwölf angegeben und die
nächste frage wer ist die nummer 68
gerade oder ungerade hat er auch evan
angegeben also gerade hat bisher
wirklich alles richtig beantwortet doch
dann die letzte frage ist harro also
woher weißt du dass er hat einfach
geantwortet wiek auf seinem smart ja
weil ich glaube ich sagt sie da
eigentlich nicht fall die nächste
schüler aufgabe ist wieder so richtig
bescheid ich frag mich einfach warum
lehrer schülern so etwas stellen ich
meine das ist einfach noch ohne dich so
was abzufragen
der papst in dem fall ist toni
praktisches baby and one i manager soll
der schüler hat den effekt beschreiben
also da wird man einfach nur hin
schreiben ja toni wird besser im
klavierspielen also klein diese frage zu
stellen ist einfach dumm der schüler hat
hier allerdings geschrieben
hier ist big girls dann war ich ja
großer nerd die nächste aufgabe wurde
wieder so richtig süß beantwortet sage
ich mal von einem naiven schüler und
zwar ist die aufgabe die diagramme die
laube stille straits und dann halt vier
auswahlmöglichkeiten welche
evolutionstheorie sage ich mal
dargestellt jetzt jeder der der schule
irgendwie ansatzweise aufgepasst hat
weiß dass das die evolutionstheorie von
darwin ist also dass nur die größten
überleben also die stärksten und da die
giraffen in diesem beispiel hier mit den
langen hälsen am besten
die blätter ankommen haben natürlich nur
die überlebt der schüler hat allerdings
geantwortet sie raffen sind herzlose
kreatur womit er recht wenn sie hätten
den wir auch aus abgeben können diese
aufgabe hier können wir einen relativ
schnell ab handeln und zwar wurden dort
extra punkte vergeben wenn man die frage
what is the strongest force und wenn man
diese frage nicht beantwortet der
schüler hat love geschrieben also die
liebe ist der stärkste trend aber no
shit
ich weiß nicht was die richtige antwort
gewesen wäre
gravitation also wirklich überhaupt
keine ahnung aber ich bin noch dominik
aufgabe ist so komplett sinnlos also die
auflage lauft erstmal droht picture of
wort die jugendmusik in one hundred
years in mord handelt iris blablabla
sobald ihr soll und dann soll man sich
wahrscheinlich dahin malen mit war und
ausgefallenen haken krückstock und dem
wasser doch die person diese aufgaben
und es ist einfach nur richtig wenn die
aufgabe zehn punkte gegeben hätte ich
hätte dir 40 gegeben
das ist einfach nur richtig in 100
jahren ist man tot was ist ein porträt
ist nicht irgendwie eine nahaufnahme vom
gesicht müde dass ist ein französisches
gebäck komplett korrekt wenn ein kind
diese schüler antwort gegeben hätte die
ich euch jetzt hier gleich aufdecken
werde dann hätte ich hätte ich denen
gesagt kommt bringt schule abwehrt
comedian die aufgabe ist wenn andere
durch ein mikroskop schaut kann sie
trotz florist dirigierenden ich weiß
nicht mal was das haupt stoff auf der
zellmembran nichts erkennen woran könnte
das liegen also warum erkennt sie nichts
trotz dieses fluoresziert
der wind sehr heftig sein bis sie dann
diese antwort aus der letzten folge hast
zehn pixel jemand fragte ich nach zwei
keksen wie viele kekse hast du noch zehn
machen wir allerdings nun auch direkt
weiter mit der nächsten schüler antwort
und zwar wurde das hier gezeigte in
einer klassenarbeit einfach zwei mäuse
und darunter sollte man hin schreiben ja
was das ist also die mäuse der schüler
hat geschrieben die muss ja es ist nicht
richtig bei dieser antwort habe ich mich
wirklich wieder gedacht hey da würde ich
trotzdem punkte für vergeben
das ist die frage welche bewegung führt
der radfahrer aus und er schreibt
vorwärts was ja richtig ist doch dann
soll man das begründen
und er fährt nicht rückwärts es ist
richtig er fährt nicht rückwärts es
wirklich würde zumindest heil punkte
vergeben das gleich auch wieder bei
dieser aufgabe hier her greift das
richtig andere allerdings die begründung
ist halt so ist also ganz also wenn man
es ganz dumm betrachtet ist es halt auch
wieder richtig
es ist halt so aber das ist nicht das
was berlin natürlich dabei gedacht hat
wie wird milch hergestellt
da muss man die kuh fragen ich fühle
mich so dumm wenn ich das die ganze zeit
sage aber es ist richtig natürlich
können wir aufgrund von geologischen
erkenntnissen
und keine ahnung was herausfinden und
begründen warum die kuh milch herstellen
kann allerdings wie sie das macht das
wirklich nur die kuh also keine ahnung
wissen wie also dieses schüler test
antwortet wieder so richtig bescheid
also die erste frage ist wie weit es die
erde von der sonne entfernt er schreibt
einfach doppelt so weit wie doppelt so
weit also da der zu recht null punkte
für gekommen und die zweite frage ist
warum hat der planet saturn ring
die antwort ist gott liebt den saturn
und hat ihm einen ring gegeben der auch
null punkte für bekommen bei der
nächsten aufgabe wird gefragt deine
mutter kaufte er eine jacke für 70 euro
und eine hose für 90 euro was ergibt
dass streit mit meinem vater ist richtig
allerdings ist das nicht die einzige
frage in der klassenarbeit oder diesen
test sondern es wird das auch gefragt
robert hat 50 kekse er ist 35 davon auf
was hat er dann einen besuch im
krankenhaus hätte ich wieder humor
punkte verteilt das ist ein hashtag
falls sie es nicht wusste übrigens bei
ganz kurz hier zwischen münchen er sei
ein bisschen musiklehre hier mit luca
hat ihr soll jemand ein fach deutsch
eine kurzgeschichte verfassen mit den
themen religion sexualität und geheimnis
und die kurzgeschichte ist oh gott ich
bin schwanger wenn ich nur wüsste von
wem hätte ich direkt gesagt komm eines
mega gut alles andere sachen
untergebracht also wirklich was manche
spieler denken das ist wirklich wahnsinn
dass hier jetzt wieder seine standard
lustige schüler an bord finde ich also
wo liegt und er schreibt da so das ist
genau das mit fix und dann umkreisen die
leute ickx und schreiben
wie nennt man die kraft der
beschleunigung porsche kinder erklärte
den begriff vakuum leer
es ist es ist einfach wieder richtig
hier sollte ein schüler ankreuzen was
für ihn heimat ist und er hat
verschiedene sachen angekreuzt wie
beispielsweise der ort an dem ich
geboren bin oder dort wo meine familie
und freunde leben aber bei der eigenen
antwortete angegeben dort wo ich wlan ab
was auch wo ich will also da denke ich
mir halt wie kann man überhaupt bei so
einer frage punkte vergeben weil für
jeden bedeutet heimat ja eigentlich was
anderes um jetzt allerdings hier soll
ein rundes ende für diese schüler test
antworten lustig folge wie auch immer
das heißen dass du so nach unten folge
zu machen ist die nächste aufgabe wieder
die darwins theorie also die
evolutionstheorie mit den fischen hier
sollte man das erklären und er schreibt
der kleinste verliert fische sind
grausam erinnern uns an die giraffen die
ja auch herzlose tiere sind ja schreibt
mir die kommentare wenn er mich
entscheiden müsste
fische oder giraffe was werd dir gern an
der stelle wird das heutige video gar
nix auch beenden meine damen und herren
wenn euch meine reaktion auf einige der
dünnsten lustigsten schüler antworten
gefallen hat das gerne mal ein leid da
soll ich davon einen dritten teil noch
hochladen
also es gibt unfassbar viele lustige
schüler antworten überall im netz
verteilt und mir macht es mega spaß
darauf zu reagieren weil ich so was mega
lustig finde schreibt sie gehen und die
kommentare lassen leiten das noch mal
machen soll und dann will ich wieder
beenden
[Musik]
ein